este viernes en una proyección de unidad
los líderes europeos llegaron juntos a
la Cumbre de Praga una imagen que no
escondió las profundas divisiones sobre
cómo gestionar el aumento del precio del
gas 15 de los 27 estados miembro quieren
Establecer un límite máximo al precio de
las importaciones pero otros argumentan
que la medida podría conllevar el
desabastecimiento
Hubo mucho debate sobre el apoyo
financiero que distintos estados han
llevado adelante lo que ha provocado
ciertas tensiones en distintas capitales
europeas
muy bien considerando que cada país
recibirá más o menos gas en función de
su situación financiera nacional el
presidente francés Emmanuel macron opinó
que una forma de paliarlas
desaveniencias entre los estados miembro
es crear un fondo europeo como se hizo
durante la pandemia de Kobe 19 por otro
lado la presidenta de la comisión
europea señaló la necesidad de alcanzar
un acuerdo entre los 27 a corto plazo
para el final del Invierno cuando
hayamos agotado nuestras reservas va a
ser primordial que adquiramos el gas
conjuntamente y evitemos hacernos la
competencia entre nosotros
mientras el precio del gas se ha
multiplicado por 5 respecto al año
pasado el bloque espera llegar a un
acuerdo para limitar la escalada en la
próxima Cumbre del 20 de octubre entre
tanto los ministros de energía tienen
otra oportunidad de buscar consensos en
una reunión de la próxima semana